[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm going to be joined here at the
interval in san francisco by our speaker
today
praerna singh who comes to us through a
partnership that we have had for several
years
with kasbas the center for advanced
studies and behavioral sciences at
stanford
praerina has been studying virology
pandemics
nationalism and most importantly at this
point vaccine acceptance and how all
these things come together
and tonight she's going to give us a
history of that as well as how it might
apply to our present situation
here in our own pandemic welcome purna
singh
thank you xander it's an honor to be
here at the long now foundation
and in my research i look to the past to
understand how to promote human
flourishing
today and in the future and in that i
see my aims as very much
in alignment with the goals of the
foundation
so infectious diseases have posed one of
the most serious and long-standing
challenges to humankind
especially since settled agriculture and
the domestication of animals
infectious diseases have not only been
the single largest
cause of human morbidity and mortality
they've also generated enormous social
tumult
triggering the economic reversals of
fortunes and the collapse of once mighty
political empires
and decisively shaped the trajectory of
world history in the past couple of
centuries but especially in the 20th
century we have made
unprecedented medical advances in
research and treatments
and yet covet 19 is a stark reminder
of the grave threat that we continue to
face from a host of deadly diseases
naturally occurring but also the use of
germs
as a tool of bioterrorism
for me as a social scientist the control
of infectious disease
represents a fertile and yet relatively
under explored site of interactions
between the state
and its people so historically the
control of disease has been an
important driving force for the
development of states
as we think of them today so charles
tilley famously argued
that wars make states and yet
historians have shown that in as much as
military conflict
it was war against an often more deadly
foe than an enemy army disease that
prompted the extension of the state
into previously autonomous social
domains
on the one hand contagion prompted the
development of institutions of control
civilian law enforcement agencies police
customs migration
intelligence services quarantines
and pandemics led to the establishment
and strengthening of health
bureaucracies
city health boards that marked the
exertion
of unprecedented state power over
societal actors like the church
city boards regularly overruled the
clergy
in prohibiting festivals processions and
gatherings
on the other hand contagion also
encouraged the development of
institutions of care
such as poor laws relief for the needy
that underlay the emergence
of welfare states the control of disease
and healthcare in general
thus gradually went from being a private
realm
dominated by religious and kinship-based
organizations
to being recognized as within the
jurisdiction of
and then also a key responsibility
of a state towards its people so
roosevelt famously said that the success
of failure of any government in the
final analysis
must be measured by the health of its
citizens
and key to this is the protection
against disease
but if we think of conceptualizing how
capable states
are in terms of how effectively they
control
infectious disease it's important to
recognize that this
is a particular type of state capacity
that rests critically on a state's
ability to gain compliance with society
so let's think for a second of the
typology of the kinds of activities that
states
regularly undertake on the left you have
tasks that states can achieve without
much
active participation from society
economic planning the dispensation of
justice
building of public infrastructure on the
right
on the other hand are activities that
states cannot be successful at
without the compliance of society so the
best organized elections are only
successful if people vote
volunteer armies can only be raised if
people join them
a state's tax base often its main source
of revenue
rests on people willingly fairly paying
taxes
a state's public health policy is only
as successful
as the extent to which people comply
with it
historically states have elicited
compliance with their policies
on this rough spectrum from coercive to
voluntary
on the coercive end forcible inspection
raiding of homes
separations of patients from families
segregation of contacts
compulsory sterilization compulsory
vaccination laws that may or may not
be accompanied by force but such
coercion
is far from ideal it's costly to
implement you need to have information
you need to monitor and punish those who
are evading
and further coercion risks societal
pushback
through much of history people have gone
to great lengths to resist public health
mandates
in india colonial reports document how
families hid
plague victims in lofts in cupboards
in gardens in addition to such evasion
across much of the world coercive public
health policies have provoked
protests uprisings violent riots
even assaults on and the assassinations
of state employees
moving across the spectrum away from
coercion many states stop
short of making vaccines compulsory but
they may require them for access to
state resources schooling
employment and at the very end of this
scale we can think of compliance with
public health interventions
that is voluntary willingly extended
this is the most desired type of
compliance
but it is also the most elusive it
represents a category
within state tasks that require popular
participation
that following a group of fellow new
england economists i call
wicked hard so for one public health
is preventive unlike when we take a
pharmaceutical drug like a painkiller we
are not sick or suffering
when we undertake a public health
intervention we are taking that action
preemptively to protect us in the future
and we know from many studies that
humans tend to be presentist
we discount the future public health
advice
can because of its link to science be
dynamic and also possibly contradictory
this can be hard to process and further
public health interventions require
behavioral change
behavioral change that is intense and it
is intimate
therefore michelle foucault's term
biopower
public health directives entail
incursions testing
incisions into our bodies and those of
our often very young children
changes to our everyday established
habits and routines don't smoke
exercise wear a condom public health
directives
can as the cove pandemic has reminded us
upend how we live they can change how we
die
alone or with our families they can
modify the rituals through which our
loved ones
remember us and send us onwards
in doing so they can rub against often
long-held
norms beliefs and practices they can
challenge ways of seeing and being in
the world
and they can lead us to question who we
are what we know
and our place in this universe
compliance with
many public health directives such as
vaccination
like some of those other tasks in the
second column voting
taxation conscription they represent
what we call
collective action problems so although
society is better off
if all comply with their tax duties
each individual has an incentive to free
ride
on the contribution of others similarly
for vaccination
collective action is necessary to attain
herd immunity
but once it is reached the benefits of
decreased mortality and morbidity are
available to all
so given that like almost all health
interventions
vaccines entail some risks a poke
some side effects individuals have an
incentive to
enjoy the benefits of that common good
to take advantage of this positive
externality of herd immunity conferred
on them
by others decisions to vaccinate without
themselves
bearing any of those costs so how then
do you encourage compliance with such a
wicked hard task
in this next part of the talk i'll try
to answer this question by taking you on
a journey of how the world's first
ever vaccine was received in two of the
largest nations
and oldest civilizations in the world
china
and india vaccines have been hailed as
the single
most important intervention in public
health immunization against infectious
diseases has protected more children and
adults from
untimely deaths than any other form of
treatment
the world's first vaccine was against
smallpox
one of the oldest and deadliest diseases
to afflict mankind
it claimed about one in three lives that
often lets left survivors blinded
and almost certainly disfigured faces
rendered this
pitted pockmarked lunar landscape it was
also a highly
virulent contagious disease and this
importance of smallpox is one of
history's greatest killers
is rivaled by its significance as the
subject
of quote the world's most triumphant
achievement
in medicine and public health the global
dissemination of the vaccine
led to the eradication of smallpox
through a global worldwide campaign led
by the who
it is to date the only human disease
to be eradicated from the globe both
china and india have very long histories
of smallpox they compete for the
orientalizing moniker of the cradle of
smallpox
both had highly well developed and
surprisingly resonant systems of beliefs
and practices around the disease
in line with the diseased deities that
existed across much of the world
china and india had smallpox goddesses
toshen nyangyang
in china and sitalamata in india
and the two goddesses are strikingly
similar as you can see
in their visual representations in both
china and india there were traditional
medical systems that saw smallpox as a
disease
of heat and patients followed a cooling
diet
beginning around the 16th century both
china and india witnessed the emergence
and spread of a new technique
which was embedded within and
accompanied by these rituals
the prophylactic practice of variolation
variola is the small box virus in order
to understand
how variolation worked let's think for a
moment of how
a vaccine works the fundamental idea
behind a vaccine
is that if we are deliberately exposed
to a relatively
harmless or the dead version of a germ
our immune system will then
recognize and eliminate that germ
rapidly if it encounters it out in the
world
this logic comes from the practice of
variolation which was an essential
precursor to vaccination
say you were a child in china or india
at this time
who was lucky enough to survive a case
of smallpox
a various later usually an itinerant
folk healer and not a classically
trained physician
who charged quite a sum for their
services would collect some material
from your smallpox store
remember this is a key way in which
smallpox spread
and then use these scams to produce a
mild
but protective infection in other
children
the technique differed it was
administered through nasal encephalation
in china
and cutaneous incision into your arm in
india
so if i was a child being violated in
canton
i would snort your scabs up my nose and
in calcutta the very later would scratch
it into my skin
very much like a modern day vaccine both
techniques were equally effective
so this technique of variolation was
carried from china and india into the
ottoman empire
and introduced through the advocacy of a
heroic lady
lady mary montague into britain
valuation then spread across much of
europe also to north america
and this innovation from asia led to
substantial decreases in mortality
across
other parts of the world this is edward
jenner
and he is credited with inventing
vaccines
when he was eight jenna was inoculated
like thousands of other children in
england
later as a doctor in rural england
interacting closely with dairy maids who
had a reputation for being especially
beautiful
the reason they did not have a quote
ugly
pockmarked face they reported to jenner
was because they were protected from
smallpox because they had gotten cow pox
now exposure to cow pox was a pretty
nasty disease if you were a cow
but it was quite benign if you were a
human and it protected you
against smallpox jenner took this
folk wisdom and replaced the various
matter the smallpox scabs that were used
in variolation
with matter from the pustules of the cow
voila variola vaccinate latin
for smallpox of the cow the world's
first ever vaccine
in 1796 which coined the term
vaccine itself now this vaccine
cloaked in the colonists language of
spreading civilization
is sent back to china and india homes of
the indigenous knowledge upon which it
was built
but from here on from the time that the
vaccine arrives in china and india at
the beginning of the 19th century
to the eradication of smallpox in the
mid 20th century it is two
very distinct stories in general a far
greater
willing compliance with the vaccine in
china than india
i use my comparative historical analysis
of the cities of canton and calcutta
in china and india during the 19th
century and of the countries themselves
in the mid 20th century to develop
what i call a moral theory of compliance
what do i mean by this a moral theory of
vaccination has two components
the messenger who is asking for
compliance
and the message how is compliance
elicited how is it framed
what is it that compliance is being
sought for
this moral theory is rooted in a
fundamentally different understanding of
us
and how we think and behave than the
much criticized
and yet dominant rational actor model
homo economicus is a rational interest
maximizer
in order to get homo economics to comply
with the public health intervention
you just need to give her some more
information about it costs and benefits
homo economics will tally this
up and if the advantages outweigh the
risks would she roll up her sleeve
and yet we know that facts don't change
our minds studies have shown that
providing people
more information about vaccines is not
only
often ineffective it can actually
backfire
in contrast research in social
psychology but also
increasingly in neuroscience shows that
we develop
attitudes and take actions in much more
complex
ways unlike homo economicus who
processes information in a neutral
bayesian manner
and maximizes interests homomoralis
thinks and acts in biased motivated ways
so to return to my moral theory of
compliance who is asking people to
vaccinate
must have a relationship of authority of
trust
of legitimacy with the people and the
message matters
my research brought out how public
health messaging is more likely to
resonate if it fits with two sources of
motivation
cognitive and affective and i'll discuss
each in turn
let's begin with the cognitive we strive
as humans for cognitive consonants we
are more likely to accept
new information as the sociologist leon
festinger said
if we can find a schema through which to
link the stimulus to previously
understood experiences
immortavisky and daniel kahneman
famously
had the familiarity heuristic that a
statement
compatible with established beliefs or
understandings
it feels more familiar it leads to a
sense of cognitive ease
and the statement is therefore more
believable
information that is not cognitively
compatible
that constitutes a rejection of what we
know
is more likely to in turn be rejected at
least initially
so in the city of canton in imperial
china in the early 19th century
vaccination was willingly adopted and a
key
reason for this was that it was promoted
by the local gentry
the gentry are either state officials or
they're closely linked to the state
through their having been conferred a
degree in the imperial exam
system but they also have strong ties to
society a system of confucian norms and
the mandate of heaven
prompts the local gentry over many
centuries to be responsible and
accountable
for the welfare of people so they enjoy
a long legacy of trust and authority
and the way that the gentry endorses
this new generation vaccine
was by embedding it within traditional
established
ways of thinking about and treating
smallpox
one of the ways that the gentry promoted
vaccination was by writing prefaces
for a vaccination manual written by one
of the first vaccinators in southern
china
chiroshi who had learnt the technique
from the surgeon general of the east
india company alexander pearson
joshi's manual was technically a
translation of a manual
written by pearson but the translation
did a few things to creatively link
the vaccine to the principles and
practices of chinese
medicine for one church she got rid of
this whole
method of inoculation discovered in the
kingdom of england so he changes the
title
he adopts the writing style and the
illustrations of traditional chinese
medicine texts a further sinusization
is that he adopts the same pre and
post-operative
dietary and ritual protocols that had
accompanied violation
and finally remember that varioulation
had happened in canton through nasal
encephalation you're snorting the scabs
up your nose
and now in the vaccine there is an
incision into the arm
by a vaccination lancet that is
radically new
now chushi and the gentry who are
endorsing his manual
make this acceptable by linking it to
the familiar
needling technique of acupuncture
vaccination manuals such as this
use ornate illustrations in traditional
drawing styles
to show vaccinators how to make
incisions along
acupuncture meridians that corresponded
with smallpox
the customary cooling diet was also
maintained and often the general vaccine
was accompanied by traditional
herbal formulas in contrast the vaccine
meets with a
far cooler reception in 19th century
calcutta it arrives at exactly the same
time in both canton and calcutta it's
introduced by the same agent the east
india company
and these cities are key entrepreneurs
in the european especially the british
trading system
in fact trade between calcutta and
canton silver
tea and eventually opium is the
lifeblood of british imperialism
and you can get a sense of the
importance of the two cities from this
painting of the three
money brothers all employed by the
british east india company
that was commissioned by their father mr
money where the fingers of robert and
james
money are pointing to canton and
calcutta respectively
so calcutta shares many socioeconomic
political similarities with canton
but unlike in canton the vaccine in
calcutta is resisted
an important reason is that british
colonial officials
do not have the same degree of trust or
legitimacy as the gentry
further because the colonists spread a
vaccination was part of a civilizing
mission
this led them to present the vaccine as
something totally new
and different from the established
practice of valuation
especially the worship of cethula in
which variation was embedded
so variolation which as i mentioned was
very effective
and in fact formed the basis of
knowledge on which jenner built
was now described by the east india
company in calcutta as
backward and is dangerous and yet
even though the technology of the
vaccine was very similar to variolation
much more similar than in canton because
people were accustomed to having an
incision into their skin
yet most residents of calcutta and the
surrounding areas of bengal
avoided vaccination and continued to
prefer variation
in colonial documents you repeatedly see
reference to how a big reason for this
was
what medical historian david arnold has
termed the quote
raw secularity of vaccination this is a
quote from one of the vaccine reports
that says
that the principal objection to
vaccination
was that it was done without any puja or
worship
or sacrificial offering unfortunately
the bulk of my archival sources for this
period are colonial documents
and these are unsurprisingly laced with
the racist judgments of their writers
colonial officers in the service of the
east india company
like the money brothers and the
resistance of indians to the vaccine is
attributed to their superstition their
prejudice
but in fact the way in which vaccines
were framed constituted
a cognitive and cultural rupture with
the cohesive
elaborate and in many ways quite
sophisticated system
of understanding and treating smallpox
it's interesting to note here that many
of the instances in calcutta in which
the vaccines were
accepted was when they were accompanied
by
all the same rituals that had
accompanied variation
so middle class households who could
afford it chose an auspicious
day for the operation they observed the
old rituals the dietary taboos they
employed a priest
and as arnold writes somewhat
tongue-in-cheek
they thanked sithala rather than jenna
sahib
for the child's safe passage
fast forward more than a sanctuary india
in the 1970s at the peak of the world
health organization's global smallpox
eradication campaign
smallpox has been eradicated in africa
south asia is one of the last
outposts of the virus and the who has
shifted from a strategy of universal
vaccination to what is known as
surveillance
containment a zealous and committed
cardras of indian doctors and health
workers and foreign epidemiologists are
going from village to village
to locate cases of smallpox and
vaccinate
all contacts in a ring to stop
transmission of the virus
now if you read the report of this
campaign a somewhat dry document
called the management of smallpox in
india it's dedicated to a spiritual
leader
neem karoli baba by all accounts an
extraordinary mystic who was also the
guru of ramdas timothy leary krishna das
but how it was that this report penned
by a doctor from san francisco dr larry
brilliant
came to be dedicated to neem karoli baba
i'll let you figure that out and the
hint is that you might want to dig into
the archives of the long now foundation
seminars
but if you read this report and other
reports you can see the importance
of smallpox zero teams as they were
called
convincing local notables religious
leaders to endorse the vaccination
and how important this was for them to
convince people
to roll up their sleeve further even
though there was a substantial foreign
and western presence and role
in the campaign under the advice of
culturally sensitive
epidemiologists like dr brilliant they
were
very aware of the cultural morals and
rituals
associated with sitala indeed the
smallpox zero teams
realized that the families of smallpox
patients
might evade them but they would never
hide from the goddess
so they camped at sitla mandirs to
detect cases
and convince family members to be
vaccinated
and they often set up vaccination
stations at
sitala temples in doing so they actively
presented themselves
as working with indeed even devotees of
the goddess sithila
rather than working against her by this
time smallpox had been effectively
eradicated from china for about two
decades
communist china mao had taken power in
1949 was able to eradicate smallpox
through a mass vaccination campaign
in the early 1950s so in line with that
first
messenger component of my moral theory
of compliance
a large part of the success was because
the vaccination campaign was launched by
the chinese communist party
who enjoyed a tremendous degree of
legitimacy having emerged out of decades
of long
bitter fighting first with the gomendang
and then the japanese
vaccination had the full support of mao
who was hugely popular in the 1950s
this is still well before the disasters
of the great leap forward and the
cultural revolution
and at the grassroots level it was
communicated by the communist party
cadres who were deeply embedded in and
enjoyed the trust
of local communities vaccination was
part of the patriotic health campaigns
you were getting vaccinated to protect
the health of your nation
and this gets to this second affective
source of motivation
in my moral theory of compliance so i
tried to present
evidence for compliance because of
cognitive motivations that public health
directives were more likely to be
accepted
if they were linked to our established
beliefs norms and practices about
sickness and health
but willingness to vaccinate and
compliance with health interventions
more broadly
is also greater if it taps into our
affective sources of solidarity
what i have in my previous writings
called a sense
of weakness nationalism is a
particularly potent form of
venus in my first book i showed how
feelings of national solidarity lead to
a perception of a linked
fate a shared destiny which helps put in
place social policies for the common
good
indeed nationalism has been a powerful
driver of popular mobilizations
against colonialism across asia and
africa from the 40s to the 60s
against communism across eastern europe
and the former soviet union
in the 1990s and states have effectively
drawn
on this powerful motor of nationalism to
encourage compliance with those tasks
that present collective action dilemmas
remember getting citizens to pay their
taxes
joining your army and possibly laying
down your life for your country
so in conclusion compliance with public
health interventions remains one of the
most
pressing challenges of our time we can
see this today
in the challenges of attaining herd
immunity against kovid
but before and beyond in 2019 the who
identified vaccine hesitancy as one of
the top
10 threats to global health effectively
addressing this challenge begins from a
better understanding of ourselves
a humbler understanding homo morales is
a messy
motivated emotional decision maker
but also a richer understanding we are
driven
not just by maximizing our narrowly
defined
interests but also by our perceptions of
trustworthiness legitimacy by norms and
values by
shared identities and solidarities we
are mere mortals but we are also
moral mortals and this is our strength
thank you well that was really fantastic
um i'm here today next door to the
interval uh at the hang gallery because
now the interval our headquarters and
bar and cafe is now fully open
but i'd love to welcome uh purna singh
who's joining us
for the questions from her home in
providence rhode island welcome berna
thank you so much sanja it's a pleasure
to be here so great to have you
uh and i'm glad that you were able to do
your fellowship out at stanford during
the summer and we were able to record
your talk here
then um but also glad to have you here
live from your home
um and um in a little bit we're actually
going to be joined by
uh by dr larry brilliant who uh you
featured in the talk and in your in your
work
um and um really great to have him as
about the previous speaker and as well
as
you know as you mentioned one of the
people who led the efforts to you know
eradicate one of the only
truly eradicated disease so um i'm sure
that would be great
um i wanted to get into a couple
questions that i have and we'll also
bring some questions in from there our
live audience
um one of the first things i want to
talk a little bit about is this jenner
story i mean he's often you know
he's credited as a as an inventor or a
discoverer and
yet he really was was act you know
bringing folk knowledge into
um a more common and modern practice and
how do you how do you like to talk about
invention versus discovery and how these
things
um get brought into the i guess it would
call the modern world
to some extent i think you know
invention discovery but also the kind of
impetus of what was happening just the
geopolitics of colonialism of the time
and how quickly that shifted you know so
vaccines are so interesting historically
because they really represented in many
ways the first
thing that kind of the the europeans had
on the colonies or so they thought you
know so this was an a clear
to them kind of something better than
what existed of course what that meant
was that they had to completely discard
and deliberately in a way undermine
the knowledge upon which the discovery
or the invention
of the vaccine was built and so suddenly
violation was backward it was suspicious
i mean of course it was dangerous the
key thing about variolation
was that you know it would be the
equivalent would be actually giving
someone a case of covet
a controlled case of covid but like
covet because these are transmissible
diseases the danger was that it was
transmissible
in the way that of course you know
you're not contagious when you get a
vaccine
and so of course there were dangers
associated with violation but
in one fell stroke with the kind of
colonial
discovery the british discovery the
western european
discovery it suddenly became that you
know the knowledge violation was
was painted as extremely dangerous very
backward
and so i think there are all these kind
of politics um in which kind of
vaccination represents a really
important moment
both for public health but also for the
understanding of geopolitics and your
question about
invention versus discovery i think gets
to the gets right to the heart of it
indeed i think you know there's such an
interesting nationalistic component to
this which you know we're now seeing
with
vaccine hesitancy having nationalist
elements now with covet
and you know we often see people trying
to use facts to change minds
but i think you really pointed out um
you know both in
in uh larry brilliant's work and in this
other work that you kind of have to meet
people where they're at
you have to people both physically and
and culturally
and i'd love if you could just talk a
little bit more about that and maybe
how that might apply better to the
situation we're in now
you know the fact that at that and those
very last stages
of the eradication of smallpox it wasn't
necessarily that they were giving people
more information
about the disease in fact if anything
smallpox was a disease that was all too
familiar to people
but i think you know the way that i put
it in the in my
in the talk and the way that i talk
about it in my book
is about both the kind of cognitive and
the affective so both you know where
as you said where are we at in terms of
almost everyone
has certain sets of norms and
understandings about what makes us sick
and what's going to make us healthy and
i think kind of understanding
what people think of as making them sick
and and making them
well is really important we know that
there's an association in the u.s
between people
who believe in alternate forms of
medicine
and a certain degree of vaccine
hesitancy we knew this prior to the
covet pandemic
so again trying to understand you know
what what is their world view
what is their understanding and to meet
that not with aggression or with
skepticism
or with hostility but to kind of really
meet it from a point of
meet that point of view from from a
stance of empathy
and then to kind of you know bring that
on board
uh as well as as i said so that's the
message part of it and the second part
is of course who is doing this
convincing
i think you know the kind of the agent
of persuasion has to be
and we've seen this again with kovid
someone who enjoys
the trust a degree of legitimacy on the
part of the people
and that might be a state official it
might be your pediatrician because
most diseases covid is very different in
some ways because it's a
actually unusual disease that we are
vaccinating ourselves as adults
for most infectious diseases we receive
vaccines as children
and so i think you know in in some ways
the pediatrician or the doctor
so we have to kind of really work hard
both into developing our understanding
of a sympathetic understanding of of
people's repertoire
their norms about what constitutes
sickness and healing
and then you know the understanding what
their
what their kind of ecosystem of trust
and authority and legitimacy is
and the final thing that i'll say before
i turn it back to you xander
is that i think of nationalism here as
both
as both the promise but also the pitfall
of it and i think we sometimes tend to
talk about the drawbacks of nationalism
which are all too evident in the kind of
tragic vaccine nationalism that
continues
you know in india where i'm from there's
still a huge degree of vaccine
scarcity and yet we have this vaccine
abundance in the u.s
and much of this is a product of the
kind of vaccine nationalism
through which vaccines are being
distributed against covet
but i do want to kind of point out to
that part of my research that shows how
nationalism can be this affective motor
so if facts don't change our mind what
does right
so having vaccines be linked to the way
that we think about
health and healing will change our mind
but also it being linked to this
emotion you know how what are we
motivated by emotionally
and i think their nationalism has been
such a powerful motivator
of humans historically since the
beginning of the nation state people
have been willing to lay down their
lives
for the nation and so i think you know
again the experience of the patriotic
health campaigns but also the experience
of
cuba and many other countries points to
how nationalism
can be mobilized as this very powerful
affective tool even though it remains
this kind of very dangerous divisive
force as well
so you know you're right information
doesn't change our mind
but i try to want i want to kind of try
to focus on what does
change our mind and how we can take
those lessons to our understanding of
the present and the future
thank you and uh this would be a great
time to bring in uh
larry brilliant um he's joining us from
his home actually not too far from us
welcome larry
hello xander thank you for inviting me
and brandon that was
wonderful both your talk right now and
your book
and the form i i came away watching your
your talk with the same feeling i had
when i read your book how could one
person
know so much really a pleasure to
spend some time with you thank you so
much i cannot tell you what an
immense honor it is to have you join the
conversation and i'm so grateful to you
when you talk about meeting people where
they are
probably no place in the world has there
ever been a more
legitimate reason to have an anti-vaxx
movement than india because in order to
make the vaccine
you had to take cows and
imprison them and scarify their belly
and implant
pops and then harvest it and kill the
cow
so in order to get the vaccine the death
of something sacred and honored and
loved
in india a cow uh so
we we encountered a a tremendous amount
of resistance i wouldn't call it
resistance i think it was the right
response it was so ferocious that
as you know the 1895 bengal immunity act
was created one of the very few uh
laws that was laid down because of the
calcutta um
aversion to being vaccinated so when we
were in the program and towards the end
of it
when we felt that this um reaction
against the vaccine was understandable
and legitimate
uh my wife garage and i would stay in
shitlama temples we would sleep in the
temples
we would talk to the pujaris and we
would say
look uh how could what can we do this
disease is killing children and they
would say well that's not shitless
intention
and we would talk about what was the
intentionality of the deity
and in the end we reached an
understanding
and the understanding was the pujaris
would say listen we have seven other
rash diseases
that shida lama is in charge of
maybe we can help you with this one and
when i told him that my guru had said
that
the eradication of smallpox was god's
gift to humanity
these pujaris said let us help you
and they would take us to the villages
they would sign
the uh posters they would guide us to
vaccinate people they would show us
where cases were and we could not have
eradicated
uh smallpox without the help of sheet
lama
and her priests it couldn't absolutely
i think it's you know every time i hear
it even though i've you know been in the
archives for far too long i've
you know read everything you've written
it's still such a poignant moving story
and of course it's resonant
if we go back to you know if we again go
back to this theme of learning from
other pandemics
i keep going back to ebola and the fact
that so much of the transmission was
happening through funeral rituals
and much you know the kind of advising
of people to just stop laying their
hands on the corpse was not enough
until as you kind of point out the they
were able to get the buy-in the support
the endorsement
of the religious leaders the clergy who
said you know we can kind of send the
spirits on
without the healing touch can happen you
know from afar
but i think that kind of careful
cultural work
requires you know it requires
institutions it requires
empathy and you know we were talking
before we went live that the cdc
which is such a hollowed-out institution
i mean you were part of the cdc you
and the who epidemiologists were going
across the world
because in a way the the battle against
kovid
is just we're not even there in terms of
in india there is still
so much vaccine scarcity there's also a
fair degree of hesitancy and
the international community the us the
cdc
were so critical they were at the
vanguard of the eradication
of this deadly infectious disease and
you were all there
doing this kind of work and so i can't
help but think you know
this is the kind of work we need to be
doing in the rural hinterland
in the us to be able to understand you
know what are people's belief systems
who can we reach out to convince them
what are the messages that we can
frame this within and then how can we
take this to other parts of the world
which are slowly going to begin to kind
of move from
a stage of vaccine scarcity
to vaccine abundance and reluctance the
way that we have in the u.s
so i ask you as a historian uh what
major
transformative social movement occurred
without
the religious institutions without the
churches
and then i asked the very tough question
which is right now about kovid
where are the churches where are the
temples
where the synagogues the mosques where
is the religious community
helping to vaccinate the
the country one third of the country is
unvaccinated 125 million
americans right now are completely
vulnerable
and around the world that number is
probably close to 7 billion
who are still vulnerable we won't have
enough vaccine
certainly not to waste and the united
states and the uk
have purchased three times the amount of
vaccine that we could ever use
even if we vaccinated everybody three
times so what
what will we do when india is creeping
up to three or four
percent vaccinated how how will we
engage all of the most powerful
feelings of nationalism and
in my mind the religious and spiritual
community
they've been absent from this battle
absolutely and i you know so i'm a
comparative political scientist
who takes a historical view to this and
unfortunately
that those historical lessons are are on
the one hand
quite evident and on the other hand the
kind of taking up of that lessons as you
point out larry is is missing so i think
you're right the kind of role of the
clergy that has
the role of religious institutions
that's something that needs to happen of
course in india
that has become further complicated by
the fact that of course the rise of
hindu nationalism
means that religion has taken on a very
different meaning
than when it was when you and nirja
you know whose articles i've also read
um you know i mean
i laugh every time i say it they're just
brilliant right is that
is is i think that you know so so i i
worry as you say we begin to get to that
point
in other parts of the world like in
india because that relationship
um you know of people like me who are
not necessarily on board with hindu
nationalism
how do how do those you know it's become
so religion
itself much like in the us has become so
politicized
it has become so polarized that it's not
so easy
to be able to kind of be able to take on
board
those religious leaders or religious
ideas in the way that it was
back in the 1960s and 70s and so you
know i hate to kind of
to kind of bring you know to make this
negative again a little bit
but again the content of nationalism has
changed and so to me
the kind of challenge is this recovery
this kind of moral recovery of an idea
of nationalism
that stands above ethnic divisions and
religious divisions that can motivate
people as a kind of patriotic duty
and to be able to find some idea of
religion as spirituality
rather than as these kind of religious
institutions and political ideologies
to be able to so you know to me like
vaccination is
at is at once both a spiritual duty and
a patriotic call that's how
smallpox was eradicated it was a
combination of spirituality
and you know religious leaders and norms
and trust
and nationalism and good science
and of course the good science is the
backdrop of all of this
i want to thank uh you larry for joining
us it's just it's really great to see
you as always
wonderful to see you thank you so much
and um you know last question um you
know now that you're back at home with
your family um
is what's what's next for you what's
your what's your next project where are
you what are you researching now
so getting this book done and out is
very much the so my future
right now is is not is not you know the
long now is for me
the the kind of getting this book out
because in some ways i began working on
this book when
you know vaccination and infectious
diseases are very
unsexy topics it's kind of like you know
before it was cool yeah
before it was cool so i've been working
on this for far too long
and in some ways i think you know it has
become tragically relevant today
but um but you know just the archives
can immerse you there's always so much
more but i do think i have something
quite important to say and so the
challenge for me is really
to be able to kind of get it written and
so it's a more immediate future and then
of course you know questions of public
health and nationalism
and kind of remain i think somewhere in
that kind of
more longer future nice well i'm glad
that you started as early as you did so
you would be ready to talk to us
at such a relevant moment and thank you
so much really really appreciate having
you
no thank you so much for having me it
was a pleasure
and um i'd love to thank uh dr larry
brilliant who joined us as well as well
as our production team um we have
some talks coming up in the future some
of our first live talks in over 18
months
um and even and some of those are going
to be covering uh similar subjects
such as how quarantines have worked and
i'd love to thank our venue here the
hang gallery next door for hosting us
for this q a and i look forward to
seeing you all at our next talk thank
you so much
[Music]
you